californians are angry at the people who
aren't taking the vaccines so when i'm
talking they're saying like what do we
say to these people you know and i said
like look
you got to uncoil because i really don't
think you're going to change these
people's minds by attacking you you
won't and there are going to be those
people you won't change their minds but
the people who you can get to it's going
to be through empathy what what are your
problems don't start off by talking
start off by listening and i think
that's something that we have to do more
of
you gotta uncoil wise words from our
doctor john lepuc there on the late show
with stephen colbert last night on what
we as a nation need to do to beat this
pandemic that empathy is seen every day
in the work of doctors and nurses at
hospitals overwhelmed by covet cases our
lead national correspondent david begno
visited one hospital in baton rouge
louisiana david good morning
anthony good morning we are at baton
rouge general and beds like this are
empty because there's not enough nurses
there's a shortage because of the covet
surge there are 10 patients in the er
right now waiting for icu bed and there
are none available and before you say
well go open up another icu they usually
have three icus they opened up
nine it's still not enough they still
don't have enough
louisiana is still setting records new
hospitalizations highest
hospitalizations highest case rate the
doctors are exhausted they're treating
patients who didn't take the virus
seriously initially didn't want to
believe the doctors but then ran to the
hospital and said please treat me i'm
struggling to breathe
we followed one doctor around chris
thomas we followed him for seven hours
on sunday
take a look at what we saw
let's walk you down here
come on
inside one of the covet icus here at
baton rouge general hospital dr chris
thomas is arranging a get together hey
we brought you a visitor hoping that
kerry oaks can give her husband jeffrey
the kind of medicine that only family
can
provide everybody
they have been married for 27 years and
both of them are in the icu with covet
19 and this is their second time
catching the coronavirus
they were not hospitalized the first
time and they said that they had wanted
to wait to get vaccinated we felt that
the fact that we had it last year
would give us some
additional
protection this year the delta variant
is really really nasty
and anyone who thinks that they can just
come through this
they're wrong
dr thomas's icu is full of patients like
the oaks people who are scared or
regretful
like 42 year old ronald banks who has a
three-month-old at home
[Music]
dr thomas has heard that more than once
and he knows that more patients are
coming and if history holds they will
almost all be unvaccinated every
physician who says they haven't been
frustrated at some point is not being
honest we have two pandemics we have a
pandemic of a delta virus that's
ravaging our community and we have a
pandemic of misinformation these people
are smart
they're making what i think they believe
are sound decisions as it relates to the
vaccine and i'm not frustrated at them
anymore i'm just frustrated that we've
gotten to the point where we allow
misinformation to equal medical science
they're not the same
we're losing the battle of
misinformation and it's important to win
that battle and he'll tell you in trying
to win that battle the tone and the
approach is really important that also
requires you have a relationship and
have trust and if you can do that then
then people will believe you even as
this war against coven and
misinformation continues for thomas the
students he teaches and his colleagues
every day someone makes a request and
says who can come and every day they
answer that call every day
every
every day
that's what they do
every day we took an oath we said we
were going to help people they have to
get home so you come here every day to
get them to their homes as much as
possible
dr thomas is a special guy let me tell
you he also teaches medicine at lsu and
he uses that same word that our doctor
john lopes uses
empathy
when you look into the face of someone
who said no doctor the coronavirus is
not real i don't need that shot i don't
need this medicine but then they run
here and beg for your treatment
he says david we treat him like family
every
time gail
boy dr thomas really puts it all in
perspective i think we could all use a
little empathy right now this is a very
very tough situation thank you david